- Is it normal to have a fat tongue
and is there any way to make it thinner?
Yeah sure, like if you just joined
a Planet Fitness or something
and you just like...
(clipping sound)
To be or not to be? That's the question.
You asked me other questions
and I'm about to answer them
on this episode of responding to comments,
(vocalizing)
Kaylee Mullins. Is it
harmful to eat scabs?
Mmmh, scab, ewww.
Is it harmful? Oh my God,
unless it's like a puss filled,
nah, just don't do it.
BrokenMaskPanda ThePerson.
Question: Why do my hands
prune up really fast?
My hands begin to prune in five minutes.
Are you usually like pruning while living
or are you like pruning while
you're pruning your bushes?
Are you pruning in the tub?
Are you pruning in the club?
What up bub? That went
from a very medical answer
to a very Dr. Su's answer.
Berniebeans. Is there any
way to improve memory?
Use it or you lose it? How
did I develop a good memory?
I'm sure genetics are a part of it
but I remember when I was in third grade,
you know what my savage father made me do?
When I had a reading
assignment in social studies,
he'd make me recite the
chapters word by word,
while he looks at the
book, I get one word wrong.
He kindly hands me the book back
and I go back in my room
and try and memorize it.
You use it, you peruse it.
Kulsum vizag.
Question: Is it normal
to feel physical pain
when you're in emotional distress?
Yes. I have a whole video
on how emotions cause physical pain.
And I'll tell you
something about COVID-19.
During this time, when
anxiety is an all time high,
you would think my
practice would be filled
with patients coming in talking about
their anxiety and depression.
No, it's patients
who have never experienced
physical discomfort,
meaning no aches, no pains, no injuries
are now having shoulder aches, neck aches,
backaches, muscle spasms,
and they don't know why.
Because your emotions play integral part
in your physical health,
your mental state,
your stress levels are all connected
to your physical health.
mind, body. One word.
Not only are we connected from
a neurological standpoint,
meaning that nerves are traveling
and sending signals through.
But we're also connected
through an endocrinological.
Why can't I say that,
endocrinological not chronological.
Endocrine system also
connects your mind and body.
And if you're in a prolonged state
for a chronic amount of time,
you can have results in
your physical health.
Does it matter if you drink
water while standing up
or sitting down?
Does it matter?
Is this like a full of cervical question?
Brian Shrek. Why does my eye twitch?
Mmmh,
I answered this question on the today show
and I may have given the cornea's joke.
Uniquely enough, it does
occur more in women.
So guys out there, she
is not winking at you.
- Yeah.
Her eyes just might be twitching.
I don't think it was funny.
Do you think it was funny?
Anyway, eye twitch generally harmless
but some individuals can
be predisposed to it.
Risk factors for developing an eye twitch.
Stress, obviously so we need to meditate,
calm down a little bit
more, be more mindful.
Over caffeination. There's
people that are drinking 400,
500 milligrams of
caffeine in their coffees.
That's too much.
Eye strain from cell phones, computers,
constantly staring at a screen all day.
do some relaxation exercises.
Take a break every 20 minutes.
And if it's happening quite frequently
and you don't have an answer
as to why it's happening
and it won't go away or it's really bad
where it interferes with your vision.
That's a reason to go see your doctor,
'cause there are true conditions out there
that can cause an eye twitch
that aren't just related
to your lifestyle habits.
Kianne Alvarado.
What is the best way to get rid of warts
on the bottom of the foot?
A procedure I commonly do in the office,
known as cryotherapy.
It sounds like you're getting in a chamber
and you're freezing yourself
but you're not doing that to your body,
you're just doing it to the wart itself.
In fact, there are some kits
that are available over the counter
that you could buy and
do this on your own.
But if you want a sure fire
way to get rid of the warts,
come into our office.
Usually it takes a couple of sessions
to fully get rid of the warts,
but my patients see great results.
And it's really rare to
have any adverse effects.
Grace Wisnosky.
Why do we sweat? Sweating sucks.
Arrid works, but it's not
the commercial. Sweat stinks.
Oh, that's an old commercial.
Got a major mishap.
It only seems to make me
more hot and uncomfortable.
Well, it certainly makes you uncomfortable
but it's actually making you
less hot 'cause when you sweat,
you perspire the water
evaporates off your skin,
thereby cooling the surface of your skin,
there by cooling the blood below the skin,
there by cooling your internal organs
and you see where I'm going with this?
It's thermo regulation.
If you were to overheat,
you'd be running a fever,
your body wouldn't be performing optimally
and you would eventually
die if you didn't sweat.
So thank your pores. Hug them.
Appreciate the moisture
that leaves your body.
Cheezy_Weenie.
At what part of 'becoming
a doctor' process
did you take your oath? What was it like?
You know, like I think
most medical schools
don't even make you take a proper oath,
but I remember we did.
I believe it was during
my White coat ceremony,
which happens at the
end of your second year.
And you go into your clinical rotations.
You say it out loud in an auditorium
with your fellow
classmates. It was powerful.
Some people had tears in their eyes.
I tend to not get too emotional
'cause I'm dead inside.
Lauren Farkas.
Question: Does cranberry
juice really help treat UTIs?
The evidence on this is quite weak.
The reason we recommend it,
is it's kind of benign
unless you're diabetic and
you're getting a huge sugar load.
The theory was, if you
drink cranberry juice,
you will then acidify your urine somewhat.
And then by having your
urine be more acidic,
it would thereby decrease
the bacteria colonies
in your urinary tract.
Now, when we looked at research,
it's kind of been weak to non-existent
when it comes to cranberry juice.
I know a lot of patients that still do it
cause they like 'natural remedies'.
But at the end of the day,
if you have a true
urinary tract infection,
you're symptomatic,
you don't want it to spread
higher in your urinary tract
to your kidneys and
develop a pyelonephritis.
'Cause that's already a
serious, serious condition.
'Cause complicated pyelonephritis
could warrant IV antibiotics.
Tristin drumm.
I burnt my hand really bad last night
but today it's not hurting
but I also lost the sense
of touch in my fingertips.
Is this normal?
Is it normal when you
have damaged your hand
that you experience possible
neurologic symptoms.
Yes. Is it ideal? No.
Should you be evaluated by a doctor? Yes.
Something else that happens,
when you have a burn on your hand,
you can experience contractures,
which is actually the skin,
the scar tissue that's being
laid down in lieu of the skin
can actually contract a little bit
and your hand might not be as flexible.
So these are all reasons
that you should be consulting your doctor
to make sure you have an
optimal healing process.
Darryl Hollonquest Jr.
What's the importance of
sleep for adults over 50?
Well, the importance of
sleep for those over 50
is the same that it is under 50.
Maintenance, repair and
preparation for the next day.
So get those seven to nine hours of sleep.
But just remember we've
created a new age category
for those over the age of 65
where the sleep requirements
dropped by an hour or two.
And the reason for that is,
it's harder to get the
full seven to nine hours.
It's harder to stay
asleep as you get older.
The mechanisms in your
brain sort of change.
Getting a little bit
less once you're 65 plus,
may be normal for you.
How do you know when you
should go to a specialist
rather than your primary care doctor
or pediatrician or when you should go
from one specialist to
another for the same reason?
You should, in my opinion,
almost always go to see a
primary care doctor first.
Especially if you have
a good relationship,
a long lasting one, because
then they can guide you
and tell you whether or not
you need to see a specialist.
Most reasons patients,
when they come to see me,
can be treated right then and there.
Trinity. Question: I have a double chin,
but I'm not obese and I'm healthy.
What is it and how do I fix it?
Difficult question Trinity
because I would need to
see the shape of your face,
the quality of your skin, your age.
All of these things are
taken into consideration
when we talk about your appearance.
That being said, I'm
not a plastic surgeon,
I'm not a dermatologist.
So I don't perform
procedures like injections,
skin tightening, creams, even facelifts.
All of those are potential options.
Remember, unless you have a
very enlarged, let's say neck.
Which can predispose you
to having sleep apnea.
Perhaps, you know, there's
a thyroid issue going on.
You're gonna be fine.
And the fact that you have a double chin
will not affect your life
from a physical standpoint
but if it makes you unhappy,
then it might be worth looking into.
Johnmarcus Lopez.
What can people do to prevent seizures?
It really depends on what
causes your seizures.
And a lot of times, especially
for a first time seizure,
we don't know the answer to that.
When I worked on the pediatric
ward when I was a resident,
we would have patients that would come in,
following a seizure protocol
where we would actually
try to induce the seizures
while monitoring their brainwaves
and things that we used to
do include sleep deprivation,
intense light therapy
with like flashing lights.
The question I would pose to you would be,
A. How do you know it's
definitely a seizure
that you're experiencing?
B. Have you seen a
neurologist to figure out
what type of seizure disorder you have and
C. Figure out what your triggers are.
And a lot of times that
means asking you questions
so you can figure out
what the triggers are.
Sarcoughhagus. I recently had a blood test
and it turns out I'm deficient
in the four vitamins,
H, U, G, and S. Can you
provide supplementation?
I think we're probably gonna have to
supplement quite heavily on this.
I think I'm gonna create
my own line of supplements
in these vitamins because
I like giving them away
and I won't charge for them.
I'm just gonna give them away for free.
And I know you probably
are thinking, Mike,
that's not a good business model.
How are you gonna make
money on these supplements?
But the real reward comes
from the actual H U G S
if you didn't get it
yet, where've you been?
Welcome.
The TV show friends is one
of my all time favorites.
Check out the medical scenes from there.
Some of them are pretty legit.
And if you're a fan of scrubs,
how did you miss this?
Click, click, click, click,
"yo bear, where you at?" Click
Stay happy and healthy.
(upbeat music)